on vient de le voir un bonjour monsieur
poulat envers le voir c'est pas la
première fois que le nitrate d'ammonium
est impliqué un dans des explosions
pense notamment bien évidemment à la
catastrophe de l'usiné azf en 2001
on en parle beaucoup du nitrate du
nitrate d'ammonium c'est quoi comme si
tu t'en sais exactement d'ammonium
permet notamment comme cela est expliqué
juste avant de produire des engrais donc
c'est sa principale activité c'est
également utilisé en tant que explosif
industriel dans certaines activités
alors donc c'est pas un combustible 1
c'est un comburant ce qui veut dire que
seul il ne suffit pas entraîner
combustion d'où cette première explosion
qu'on a vu à beyrouth avec de la fumée
blanche
exactement les hypothèses actuelles
exprimées potentiel départ de feu suite
à un incendie d'explosifs ou de feux
d'artifice on croit que l' enquête nous
donne plus d'information à ce sujet
alors comment est il possible qu'une
telle quantité de nitrate d'ammonium
soient entreposés dans un port en plein
centre ville d'une capitale comme
beyrouth alors c'est un objectif dans
une grave erreur qui peut qui a
plusieurs explications le gros problème
de la maîtrise des risques industriels
dans le monde entier et donc le liban
n'échappe pas à la règle
si je puis dire c'est la réglementation
le manque de réglementation dans de
nombreux états qui permet justement de
limiter le stockage ou à partir d'un
certain volume de stockage de nitrate
d'ammonium par exemple ou d'autres
substances dangereuses exil
la mise en place de systèmes notamment
de sécurité incendie
justement comment on améliore la
sécurité autour des sites de stockage de
produits aussi dangereux alors on peut
améliorer la sécurité
là en faisant des analyses de risques
permettent d'étudier les différentes
solutions techniques car chaque
stocks chaque entrepôt logistique ou
usine possédant un stockage à des
contraintes d'exploitation différentes
pour ça qu'il ya vraiment un besoin
d'études à chaque fois le souci
également quand une réglementation
existe car par exemple vous parliez d'un
cd juste avant la réglementation existe
est amère elle n'a pas été respecté car
ensuite la réglementation nécessite des
inspections d'inspecteurs formé à pour
justement vérifier la conformité des
installations par rapport à la
réglementation si elle existe et on
parle d'une réglementation nationale au
mondial commune à tous les pays
on pourrait imaginer comme sur d'autres
sujets une réglementation internationale
il faudrait néanmoins que cette
réglementation ne soit pas trop
spécifique
un car le risque c'est qu'ensuite les
systèmes ne soient pas adaptées aux
différents ce qui compte vraiment c'est
de développer également la compétence
sur les sujets en sécurité incendie et
dans la maîtrise des risques industriels
hormis les pays nordiques on cruellement
de formation universitaire sur le sujet
vis-à-vis des ministères on manque de
personnel formé également normalement ce
soit le ministère de l'intérieur soit le
ministère de la sécurité générale qui
s'occupe de ce type de sujet est
également nos architectes nos ingénieurs
nos techniciens manque cruellement de
formation sur suez et au delà du
terrible un bilan humain des dégâts
matériels at il des risques
environnementaux lorsqu'une explosion de
cette ampleur à dieu oui il ya déjà le
risque lié aux fumées 1 suite au suite à
un incendie
il y a également la pollution des sols
la pollution des eaux a notamment à se
trouve juste à côté du banc la mer
méditerranée mais également pour
éteindre l'incendié
les services de secours les pompiers
utilisent justement des moyens
d'extinction qui si aucune rétention
mais prévu à cet effet dans ce type de
catastrophes généralisée bien entendu ça
dépasse l'entendement c'est même un
système d'extinction surtout se propage
à l'intérieur de la ville de beyrouth
c'est une catastrophe pour l'ambiance
merci paul poulain d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
spécialiste des risques industriels
merci